i've gotten for the first time in my
life was a victim of a cyber attack
um
so this is ransomware it's called
deadbolt people can look it up i have a
qnap device for
basically
kind of coldish storage so it's about 60
terabytes with 50 terabytes of data on
it
in raid 5 and apparently about 4 to 5
000 qnap devices
were
hacked and taken over with this
ransomware and what what ransomware does
there is
it goes file by file almost all the
files on the qnap storage device and
encrypts them and then there's this very
eloquently and politely written page
that pops up
uh
you know it describes what happened all
your files have been encrypted this
includes but is not limited to photos
documents and spreadsheets why me
this is uh a lot of people commented
about how friendly and eloquent this is
and i have to commend them it is and
it's pretty user friendly
uh
why me this is not a personal attack you
have been targeted because of the
inadequate security provided by your
vendor qnap
what now
you can make a payment of exactly 0.03
bitcoin which is about a thousand
dollars to the following address
once the payment has been made we'll
follow up with transaction to the same
address blah blah blah they give you
instructions of uh what happens next and
they'll give you a decryption key that
you can then use
and then there's another message for
qnap that says
all your affected customers have been
targeted using a zero day vulnerability
in your product we offer you two options
to mitigate this and future damage one
make a bitcoin payment of five bitcoin
to the following address
and that will reveal to qnap the uh i'm
summarizing things here
what what the actual vulnerability is or
you can make a bitcoin payment of 50
bitcoin to get a master decryption key
for your customers 50 bitcoins about 1.8
million dollars
okay
so first of all on a personal level
this one hurt for me
um
there's
i mean i learned a lot because i wasn't
for the most part
backing up
much of that data because i thought
i can afford to lose that data it's not
like horrible i mean i think you've
spoken about
uh the crown jewels like making sure
there's things you really protect and i
have thing i have
you know i'm very conscious security
wise on the crown jewels
but there's a bunch of stuff like
you know personal videos they're not
like i don't have anything creepy but
just like
fun things i did that because they're
very large or 4k or something like that
i kept them on there thinking raid 5
will protect it you know just i lost a
bunch of stuff including uh raw
um footage from interviews and all that
kind of stuff
uh so it's painful and i'm sure there's
a lot of painful stuff like that for the
four to five thousand people that use
qnap
and there's a lot of interesting ethical
questions here do you pay them
does qnap pay them
uh do the individuals pay them
especially when you don't know if it's
going to work or not
do you wait
so qnap
said that please don't pay them
we're working very hard day and night to
solve this
um it's so philosophically interesting
to me because i also project onto them
thinking what is their motivation
because the way they phrased it on
purpose perhaps but i'm not sure if that
actually reflects their real motivation
is um maybe they're trying to help
themselves sleep at night basically
saying this is not about you this is
about the company with the
vulnerabilities just like you mentioned
this is the justification they have
but they're hurting real people
they hurt me but i'm sure there's a few
others that are really hurt
and the zero day factor is a big one you
know that their qnap right now is trying
to figure out what the hell is wrong
with their system that would let this in
and
even if they pay
if they still don't know where the zero
day is what's to say that they won't
just hit them again and hit you again
so that really complicates things and
things and that is a huge advancement
for ransomware it's really only been i
think in the last 18 months that we've
ever really seen ransomware exploit zero
days
to pull these off usually
80 of them
i think the data shows 80 of them come
down to a lack of two-factor
authentication you know so when someone
gets hit by it by a ransomware attack
they don't have two-factor
authentication on
you know their employees were using
stupid passwords like you can mitigate
that in the future this one they don't
know they probably don't know yeah and
it was uh i guess it's zero click
because i didn't have to do anything
the only thing i
well you know here's the thing
i did you know basics of you know i put
it behind a firewall
i follow the instructions
but like i wasn't i didn't really pay
attention so maybe there's like maybe
there's a misconfiguration of some sort
that's easy to make
it's it's difficult we have a personal
nas on
so i don't i i'm not willing to sort of
uh say that i did everything i possibly
could
um but i did
a lot of reasonable stuff and they still
hit it with zero clicks i didn't have to
do anything yeah well it's like a zero
day and it's a supply chain attack
you know you're getting hit from your
supplier you're you're getting hit
because of your vendor and it's also a
new thing for ransomware groups to go to
the individuals to pressure them to pay
there was this really interesting case
i think it was in norway
where there was a mental health clinic
that got hit and the cyber criminals
were going to the patients themselves
to say pay this or we're going to
release
your psychiatric records i mean talk
about hell
in terms of whether to pay you know that
is on the cheaper end of the spectrum
from the individual from the company
both you know we've seen
uh for instance there was an apple
supplier in taiwan
they got hit and the ransom demand was
50 million
you know i'm surprised it's only 1.8
million i'm sure it's gonna go up
um and it's hard you know there's
obviously governments and maybe in this
case the company are going to tell you
we recommend you don't pay or please
don't pay
but the reality on the ground is that
some businesses can't operate
some countries can't function i mean
the under reported
storyline of colonial pipeline
was
after the
company got hit and took the preemptive
step of shutting down the pipeline
because they their billing systems were
frozen they couldn't charge customers
downstream
my colleague david sanger and i got our
hands on a classified assessment
that said that as a country
we could have only afforded two to three
more days of colonial pipeline being
down
and it was really interesting i thought
it was the gas and the jet fuel but it
wasn't you know we were sort of prepared
for that it was the diesel
without the diesel the refineries
couldn't function
and it would have totally screwed up the
economy and so there was almost this
like national security
economic
impetus for them to pay this ransom
and the other one i always think about
is baltimore you know when the city of
baltimore got hit i think the initial
ransom demand was something around 76
000 it made if even started smaller than
that
and baltimore stood its ground and
didn't pay
but ultimately the cost to remediate was
18 million dollars it's a lot for the
city of baltimore that's money that
could have gone to public school
education and roads and
you know public health and instead it
just went to rebuilding these systems
from scratch and so a lot of residents
in baltimore were like why the hell
didn't you pay the 76 000
so it's not obvious you know it's easy
to say don't pay because why you're
funding their r d for the next go round
um
but
it's too often it's too complicated
you